zdf heute live ganz herzlich willkommen
an diesem abend es knallt in der politik
test chaos im pannen im probleme und
jetzt hat die union auch noch ein masken
gate an der backe ganz kurz vor zwei
wichtigen landtagswahlen in rheinland
pfalz und baden württemberg landtagswahl
werden jetzt vielleicht einige denken
langweilig interessiert mich nicht
wiederum andere sagen doch genau das ist
in diesen zeiten besonders spannend und
darum beschäftigen wir uns heute damit
und sind sehr froh dass eine dabei ist
die diese landtagswahl auch sehr
spannend findet nämlich sie die
rheinland pfälzerin giuliana townsend
ehemals zweite bei germany's next
topmodel heute model influenza in und
sängerin
[Musik]
gerne
sie liebt die große bühne und das kleine
und dann doch nicht ganz so kleine
bundesland in dem sie lebt rheinland
pfalz schönen guten abend und schön dass
sie dabei sind julian account sind ja
ich freue mich ich freue mich dass ich
dabei sein da vertrauen sind das ist
nicht nur die erste wahl die in der
pandemie stattfindet und abgehalten
werden muss deshalb gucken nämlich auch
tatsächlich viele nach rheinland pfalz
und gucken wie lief der wahlkampf läuft
die wahl
warum ist denn diese war für sie
persönlich auch besonders wichtig warum
finden sie das spannend ja ich finde es
generell sehr spannend weil sich
natürlich durch die pandemie ganz ganz
viele neue fragen und fragen wie auch
tun was kann man machen was was es
vielleicht wichtig in der zeit und
deswegen interessiert mich dahingehend
natürlich auch die wahl dann sind wir
gespannt was auch die politischen themen
sind die sie beschäftigen darauf schauen
wir gleich und wollen aber von euch und
ihm zu hause auch wissen was findet ihr
an dieser wahl interessant welche fragen
und kommentare habt ihr wie immer bitte
in die kommentare oder per e mail an
diese e mail adresse wenn ihr die zdf-
heute- app nutzt es ist nicht nur die
erste wahl unter pandemie bedingungen
sondern es ist auch der auftakt für ein
superwahljahr und was das bedeutet zeigt
uns jan frederik fischer in rheinland
pfalz und baden württemberg geht es am
sonntag los das mit spannung erwartete
superwahljahr 2021 in mainz liegt die
spd mit ministerpräsidentin dreier laut
jüngsten politbarometer vor der cdu die
mit dem eher unbekannten
spitzenkandidaten baldauf antritt doch
wer gewinnt wer verliert corona macht
die wahlen so spannend wie nie wähler
müssen mit abstand überzeugt werden
wahlveranstaltungen wandern ins netz
und das virus selbst wird zum thema
nummer eins nächste station sachsen
anhalt hier gibt es im juni einen
weiteren fingerzeig für das große finale
das findet am 26 september statt wenn
die bürger nicht nur in drei weiteren
bundesländern ihre kreuze machen sollen
sondern in ganz deutschland ausgang
offen und überraschungen nicht
ausgeschlossen nur eins ist klar
angela merkel will nach 16 jahren als
kanzlerin schluss machen
tja und interessanterweise ist das
wirklich das einzige wovon wir jetzt
sagen können also ich meine wir wissen
natürlich nicht was das ja bringen da
war das einzige was man stand jetzt
sagen kann ist dass angela merkel im
herbst nicht mehr bundeskanzlerin leidet
alles andere ist tatsächlich noch offen
und offen ist auch welche themen die
parteien in diesem jahr beschäftigen
werden frauen sind welche themen
interessieren sie denn ganz besonders
was brennt ihnen so auf den nägeln
also für mich ist besonders die
digitalisierung sehr sehr wichtig und
auch dass wir neu denken dass wir
einfach auch an klima denken und solche
geschichten sind für mich super
wichtigen leben im jahr 2021 ich glaube
dass man da noch ganz ganz viel machen
kann
ja und das sagen auch viele parteien die
die landesregierung in rheinland-pfalz
kritisieren welche tricks kritik da gibt
das werden wir auch gleich besprechen
und vor allem haben wir mit ihnen
zusammen jetzt die möglichkeit in diese
themen mal rein zu gucken werden auch
wenn es in diesem jahr kaum
möglichkeiten gab es für die parteien
richtige wahlkampfauftritte zu machen
gibt es die möglichkeit sich im netz zu
informieren und das machen sie für uns
heute abend auch es gibt nämlich den
wahlomat mit dem kann man sich durch die
positionen der parteien durchklicken und
die eigenen positionen abfragen und
genau das machen wir heute abend hier
zusammen der wahlomat ist natürlich
keine erfindung des jahres 2021 den gibt
es schon lange aber wenn alles digitales
ist natürlich gerade in diesem jahr ein
wichtiges tool um sich eine politische
meinung zu bilden wie das funktioniert
zeigen die nadal und anselm stern den
wahlomat gibt es schon setzt
1002 bereitgestellt von der
bundeszentrale für politische bildung
auch jetzt wieder für die landtagswahlen
in rheinland pfalz und baden württemberg
insgesamt 38 thesen kann man hier etwa
zustimmen oder ablehnen und so
herausfinden mit welcher partei die
eigene meinung am ehesten übereinstimmt
ausgewählt hat die thesen ein team aus
20 bis 25 jungen wähler innen
politikwissenschaftler innen und anderen
expertinnen es geht um themen wie arbeit
familie bildung oder umwelt den parteien
wurden die thesen zugeschickt sie haben
ihre jeweilige zustimmung oder ablehnung
begründet und so können am ende die
positionen der parteien miteinander
verglichen werden etwa drei wochen vor
einer wahl wird der jeweilige wahlomat
online gestellt tja und dann fangen wir
direkt an giuliana townsend klickt sich
zu hause schon mal durch und wir
besprechen gleich an welchen fragen sie
besonders lange nachgedacht haben oder
was sie besonders elektrisiert hat und
wir sehen da hinten geht schon aus genau
das land soll vorrangig ökologischen
weinbau fördern frauen sind überlegt und
wir nutzen die zeit hier im studio mit
bobby cherry anzusprechen unserem zdf
reporter aus dem studio hier in mainz
bobby das ist nicht nur für die parteien
die erste wahl unter pandemie
bedingungen sondern für alle auch für
euch als reporter für uns als
journalistin
wie läuft denn aus deiner sicht der
wahlkampf unter pandemie bedingungen in
rheinland pfalz na ja also ich glaube er
läuft in erster linie ein stück weit
unter dem radar kann man so sagen man
kriegt ja nicht sehr viel davon mit also
man kann schon konstatieren dass der
wahlkampf jetzt unter pandemie bedingung
eine absolute ausnahme situation ist für
die parteien wahlkampf das ist ja
normalerweise das sind volle hallen das
ist straßenwahlkampf stände in den
innenstädten
das ist auch mal die eine oder andere
dass der eine oder andere haustür termin
da klingelt man und reicht dann
irgendwelches wahlmaterial gegenüber das
feld alles weg was haben die parteien
also gemacht im großteil haben sie sich
studios eingerichtet um virtuell
vertreten zu sein und da laden sich dann
die jeweiligen spitzenkandidatinnen und
spitzenkandidaten ihre wahlkreis kann
nein sprechen darüber über die themen
und hoffen darauf dass sich viele
möglich also möglichst viele leute in
diese streams reinklicken
ob diese strategie aufgeht das werden
wir vielleicht irgendwann im nachgang
mal erfahren zurzeit dass er schwer
abzuschätzen viele politikerinnen und
politiker haben uns in den vergangenen
wochen gesagt man sollte vielleicht
nicht nur das negative daran sehen
sondern auch eine chance man kommt mit
personen in kontakt die früher
vielleicht den weg in die festhalle zu
großveranstaltungen gescheut haben da
ist die hemmschwelle jetzt wesentlich
niedriger vielleicht auch sich einfach
rein zu klicken in so einen stream und
sich positionen anzuhören die man sich
sonst vielleicht nicht in der halle
angehört hätte was man aber auch sagen
muss die pandemie verschiebt natürlich
total den fokus die regierenden sind
gerade ganz klar im vorteil
vor jeder bund länder konferenz nach
jeder bund länder konferenz können sich
die regierenden in dem fall jetzt die
ministerpräsidentin malu dreyer kann
sich gut präsentieren sie hat eine bühne
pressekonferenzen in denen dann über
entscheidungen gesprochen wird das sind
möglichkeiten die vor allem der
opposition fehlen zurzeit aber auch den
kleineren parteien die haben es
wesentlich schwieriger sich gerade in
der pandemie zu präsentieren
umso wichtiger ist es natürlich auch
dass es viele auch journalistische
formate im netz gibt und viele formate
auch um sich zu informieren abgesehen
von dem was die parteien selber auf die
beine gestellt haben
ich gucke mal gerade in die chats ich
sehe das auf youtube rola rola seine
oder ihre oma grüßt das freut uns
mich würde interessieren brüllen oder
hast du auch schon gewählt hast du
briefwahl gemacht nutzt du den wahl o
maten oder wie siehst du die themen die
in diesem wahlkampf eine rolle spielen
schreibt doch gerne eure fragen und
kommentare in den chat trade schreibt
auch über youtube manchmal finde ich es
schwierig bei den thesen nur mit ja oder
nein zu antworten
manchmal geht das nicht so einfach weil
die themen zu komplex sind die frage
zielt auf den wahlomat ab und dann
schauen wir uns doch mal an wie der im
einzelnen funktioniert und wo frauen
sind denn gerade so ist ich glaube das
ist frage 2 von 38 an der stelle noch
mal kurz der hinweis 38 fragen kann man
natürlich nicht alle durchklicken
aber dann gehe ich mal zu frage 2 dazu
muss ich diese these überspringen
frage 2 wäre digitale endgeräte das land
soll allen schülerinnen und schülern
kostenlos digitale endgeräte zur
verfügung stellen
ich kann mir vorstellen frauen sind dass
sie diese frage relativ klar mit ja oder
nein beantworten können aber was
natürlich dahinter steht ist die frage
nach der digitalisierung und nach der
bildung wie ist denn ihre position dazu
ja also ich stehe da auf jeden fall für
ein
ich sehe das als super wichtig auch was
quasi chancengleichheit an geht das
natürlich alle schülerinnen quasi ein
digitales ein gerät zur verfügung haben
um sich weiterzubilden um einfach an
bessere informationen zu kommen und ich
weiß auch noch damals bei mir in der
schule hatte ich super viel auch
papierkram und ganz viele zettel die
immer überall herumlagen und das wird es
natürlich auch irgendwie vereinfachen
wenn man irgendwie alles digital hatte
und auch wenn man ihm ein paar tage
krank zu hause ist muss muss irgendwie
nie jemand nach hause kommen und einem
die blätter vorbei bringen sondern das
regelt sich alles dann außerdem ist es
glaube ich auch jetzt so in der pandemie
zeit super wichtig geworden dass also
haben wir glaube ich alle gemerkt dass
die digitalen endgeräte und super viel
helfen
in dieser zeit meine schulzeit ist jetzt
echt schon eine ganze weile her bobby
wird dann wahrscheinlich auch ohne und
charmanten seien aber wahr und ich kann
mich erinnern wir hatten so ein computer
labor und das war ungefähr einmal im
jahr bei vollmond wenn der lehrer gute
laune hatte geöffnet
das war digitalisierung damals bei ihnen
ist das nicht ganz so lange her wie war
das denn bei ihnen in der schule und wie
erleben sie das vielleicht auch bei
freundinnen und freunden die
studierenden oder die vielleicht auch
noch zur schule gehen im moment wir
haben dieses homeschooling jetzt erlebt
und wie war es bei ihnen also bei mir
gab es natürlich auch werden im
computerraum aber
und das war natürlich auch jetzt nicht
mehr die neuesten computer ich glaube
wir hatten auch laptops aber die wurden
ganz ganz selten mal raus geholt aber
die waren auch nicht wirklich von von
guter qualität und das hat auch immer
extrem lange gedauert also wir haben
sehr lange auch noch den overhead
projektor benutzt bei uns in der schule
was natürlich irgendwie total wild ist
was man so glaube ich heutzutage
hoffentlich jetzt in der schule nicht
mehr möglich macht und das hat natürlich
das war natürlich seien irgendwie auch
ein bisschen veraltet und ist natürlich
dann auch immer anstrengend gewesen wenn
man dann irgendwie ne coole präsentation
vorbereitet hat auf powerpoint zu hause
auf den laptop und dann konnte das
irgendwie nicht cool abgespielt werden
und das also da gab es dann immer total
stress mit den usb sticks und so weiter
und so fort da würde ich mir natürlich
wünschen dass das mittlerweile einfacher
geht und ja das ist das ist dann einfach
cooler ist für alle beteiligten den den
overhead projektor kennen wir auch noch
sehr gut hier im channel fragt german
law fighter wie kann ich den wahl o
maten selber den wahl o maten test
selber machen
das beantwortet paid trade einfach
wahlomat in deiner lieblings
suchmaschine eingeben genau jeder kann
das zu hause im netz machen die adresse
können wir auch in die chats nochmal
rein schreiben ist ganz leicht zu finden
und dann tatsächlich auch ganz leicht
sich durchzuklicken genau das machen wir
hier jetzt auch was haben sie denn
bestimmt bei frage zwei digitale
endgeräte ja oder nein frauen sind auf
jeden fall ja nächste frage da mache ich
hier auch mal stimme zu und dann kommt
als nächstes frage 3 in rheinland pfalz
sollen weitere flächen für den bau von
windkraftanlagen ausgewiesen werden
wie wichtig ist denn für sie das thema
erneuerbare rica ich bin gerade ein
bisschen verloren hier muss ich
reingucken carlo ist unser regisseur
deshalb sagte mir wohin ich gucken muss
wie wichtig frauen sind ist denn
das thema klimaschutz erneuerbare
energien für sie also ich finde das
schon wichtig wir haben ganz viele neue
möglichkeiten die wir auf jeden fall
nutzen sollten denn es gibt den
klimawandel und ich glaube dass es wenn
wir so weiter machen dass es nicht
besser wird also sollten wir auf jeden
fall auf die erneuerbaren energien
zurückgreifen wenn wir die möglichkeiten
haben und und uns da auch einfach neue
technologien ausdenken was auch schon
ganz ganz viel passiert und ich finde
sowas irgendwie extrem spannend auch zu
sehen dass es auch anders geht und
vielleicht auch sogar besser geht und
man nicht damit die umwelt schadet dann
würde ich sagen müssen wir noch gucken
was sie klicken ja stimme zu neutral
stimmen nicht zu
das würde mich interessieren sind sie
für mehr windkraft flächen oder nicht ja
ok wunderbare stimmt schon zugestimmt
dann lassen wir sie an der stelle mal
ein bisschen weiter klicken einfach und
sie können sich durch die fragen des
wahl o maten durchklicken und ich nutze
das um hier mit bobby terrier noch mal
ein bisschen weiter zu sprechen und auch
zu gucken was denn den anderen rheinland
pfälzerinnen und rheinland pfälzer und
so auf den nägeln brennt wir haben uns
auf der straße umgehört klimawandel weil
man auch auf dem lokalen der will noch
mehr dafür machen kann und ich das
richtig finde dass man auch die kleinen
dinge verbessert eine langfristige
strategie wie es möglicherweise trotz
dieses virus nicht also nicht so
weitergeht wie bisher weil das letztlich
ja einerseits die wirtschaft ruiniert
und gleichzeitig auch die staatsfinanzen
bildung auf jeden fall also die
digitalisierung der schulen und
tatsächlich auch die digitalisierung der
unis der bobby frage an dich bildung
digitalisierung klimaschutz haben wir da
gerade gehört sind dass die großen
themen die im wahlkampf eine rolle
spielen und gespielt haben
ja tatsächlich das trifft den nagel auf
den kopf also das sind genau die themen
die den bürgerinnen und bürgern in
rheinland pfalz zur zeit absolut wichtig
sind genau danach hat die
forschungsgruppe wahlen für das zdf
politbarometer
auch jüngst noch mal gefragt und da kam
es fast genauso in diesem ranking auch
raus also an erster stelle steht
natürlich ganz klar für die menschen die
bewältigung der korona pandemie ich habe
gerade aufgelegt genau
vielleicht können wir es gerade noch mal
zeigen für alle die wichtigsten probleme
in rheinland-pfalz genau handle me 60
prozent da sieht man es ganz deutlich
dicht gefolgt dann eben von dem thema
infrastruktur und internet das haben wir
jetzt gerade unter digitalisierung
zusammengefasst dann ganz dicht dahinter
bildung und schule das ist natürlich
auch das hat sich in den vergangenen
monaten im vergangenen jahr gezeigt sehr
eng miteinander verknüpft aber daneben
auch kommt recht bald umwelt und energie
wende also eigentlich die themen die
gerade auch alle schon genannt worden
sind das sind die themen die für die
menschen in rheinland-pfalz gerade ganz
weit vorne stehen
gibt es denn da gewinnerthemen quasi für
die regierungsparteien oder sachen womit
man da besonders punkten kann oder wo
womit sie gerade besondere probleme
haben
jetzt kommt glaube ich immer auf die
sichtweise an im grunde glaube ich was
die zielsetzung angeht sind die parteien
sich größtenteils einig sagt er jetzt
niemand er möchte mehr die weniger
digitalisierung haben ja oder weniger
endgeräte das fordert niemand
tatsächlich ist es so dass jetzt durch
die pandemie viele sachen zutage
getreten sind das gilt nicht nur für
rheinland pfalz das geht natürlich für
ganz deutschland weil die probleme auch
allumfassend sind wenn wir jetzt gerade
mal diese beiden bereiche sehen
digitalisierung also digitale
infrastruktur und schule ganz eng
miteinander verknüpft da hat sich
gezeigt wo die defizite sind also das
heißt es fehlt an infrastruktur es fehlt
an endgeräten es fehlt an know-how es
fehlt an lehrerinnen und lehrern in der
masse die wissen wie man diese technik
bedient es fehlt an den menschen die es
warten
und das ist glaube ich erst mal das ziel
von allen diesen zustand zu verbessern
und jetzt ist die aktuelle sichtweise
naturgemäß unterschiedlich die regierung
bestehend aus spd fdp und grünen weiß
gerne darauf hin was in den vergangenen
fünf jahren legislaturperiode alles
erreicht worden ist und zeigt dann auch
gerne die nächsten ziele auf und sagt wo
man halt in den nächsten fünf jahre hin
möchte wenn man wieder an die macht käme
und die opposition fragt ja warum ist
man da nicht schon
längst ja also warum hat man in den
vergangenen jahren nicht viel mehr
investiert und warum hat man diese
probleme jetzt in der pandemie die so zu
tage treten nicht einfach verhindert
dadurch dass man schon mehr gemacht hat
also das ist sicher ganz ganz wichtiges
thema gerade im wahlkampf ein anderes
thema ist eben klima und ich glaube da
kann jeder von uns noch mal ein bisschen
zurückdenken an die zeit vor der
pandemie was war was man da das große
thema wir haben über frei disco future
berichtet wir haben über kreta team berg
berichtet und natürlich ist das thema in
den hintergrund getreten aber es ist
immer noch da und es nimmt auch im
wahlkampf in den wahlprogrammen der
parteien einen ganz zentralen raum ein
bei allen parteien durch die bank also
da wird diskutiert über das thema
windkraft dass wir gerade im wahl o
maten angesprochen hatten soll es davon
mehr geben soll die windkraft ausgebaut
werden es gibt forderungen auch
vereinzelt die wind den windkraftausbau
zu stoppen soll ist eine fotovoltaik
pflicht auf neubauten geben
das wird also richtig heiß diskutiert
und beschäftigt die leute daneben sind
es aber natürlich es ist eine
landtagswahl auch lokale themen also
regionale themen ist geht zb um
kommunale verschuldung von den 20 am
höchsten verschuldeten kommunen
deutschlands befinden sich elf in
rheinland pfalz das ist natürlich etwas
was im wahlkampf auch eine rolle spielt
und auch die frage wir sind ein also wir
haben hier ein flächenland
da geht es um die frage wie schafft man
gleichwertige lebensverhältnisse in der
stadt und auf dem land lassen so die
großen themen die gerade die menschen
bewegen also auch infrastruktur
verkehrsanbindungen pnv internet alles
was damit zu tun hat
zum thema windkraft schreibt mark
bachmann über youtube windkraftanlagen
finde ich auch gut allerdings muss hier
auf die anwohner rücksicht genommen
werden weil die doch recht laut sind
also auch hier treibt die userinnen und
user das thema klimaschutz um wenn man
sich anguckt das bei all dem was du
gerade genannt hast bobby das große
thema tatsächlich aber ist und bleibt
corona inwiefern ist es denn für malu
dreyer ein feature also ein fluch oder
ein segen dass sie in dieser pandemie
ministerpräsidentin es kann sie punkten
weil sie sich als macherin zeigt oder
ist es eher eine gefahr weil wenn was
schiefgeht das sehen wir ja
dabei entspannen auf bundespolitischer
ebene als gesundheitsminister dann ist
das natürlich sofort er oder in dem fall
sie wenn was schiefgeht bei dem es
hängenbleibt oder bei der es hängen
bleibt
ja also tatsächlich das ist eine ganz
spannende frage gerade ich glaube
rheinland pfalz ist jetzt was die was
die umsetzung konkreter maßnahmen angeht
selten ausgeschert also das ist schon
der die die umsetzung gewesen der linien
die in der in den bund länder
konferenzen auch beschlossen worden sind
es gab immer mal ausnahmen es wurde dann
vom vorstoß gewagt zum beispiel die
schulen doch früher zu öffnen in wechsel
unterricht zu gehen
da ist man dann wieder zurückgerudert
mit baden württemberg zusammen also im
grunde muss man sagen ist es natürlich
für malu dreyer eine unglaubliche
präsentationsfläche er sie wie wir
anfangs auch schon besprochen hatten hat
sie die möglichkeit vor einer bund
länder konferenz nach einer bund länder
konferenz öffentlichkeit zu generieren
weil die leute es interessiert sowohl im
land aber auch überregional auf der
anderen seite ist es natürlich auch ein
schmaler grat so durchweg positiv ist es
nicht weil ein falscher schritt eine
falsche entscheidung die instanzen gehen
hoch entscheidungen müssen rückgängig
gemacht werden und das kann natürlich
dann auch dementsprechend in der mist
gunst der wählerinnen und wähler sich
niederschlagen die kantine gold fragt er
auch über youtube was sagen denn die
einzelnen parteien darüber wie sie genau
die folgen der pandemie bewältigen
wollen gibt es da unterschiedliche
positionen
ja also im grunde sind sicher glaube ich
auch viele einig ja also die die jetzt
besonders leiden denen muss geholfen
werden da wird sicher über die mittel
gestritten
da wird auch sehr viel über die
verantwortung bestritten wer hat die
denn jetzt eigentlich was kann das land
machen
und wofür ist der bund zuständig aber im
grunde ist es schon so dass sich alle
einig sind die bit also die branche die
als besonders betroffen sind
das heißt wir reden hier über die
kulturbranche wir reden über gaststätten
hoteliers und ähnliches denen muss
geholfen werden tatsächlich dann würde
ich an der stelle ganz gerne nochmal zu
frauen sind gucken ins wohnzimmer frauen
sind bei welcher frage sind sie denn
gerade
frage 37 bin ich gerade so ein ferrari
37 schon okay dann sind sie ja schon
fast durch
dann würde ich sie gerne mal fragen was
sie bei frage 31 geantwortet haben die
habe ich hier mal aufgelegt und zwar ist
das quasi die korona frage die der
wahlomat für rheinland pfalz bereit hält
nämlich die frage infektionsschutz durch
den bund bei der infektions bekämpfung
soll der bund mehr
entscheidungsbefugnisse von den
bundesländern erhalten das hieße quasi
übersetzt mehr einheitliche regeln mehr
zentral gesteuerte maßnahmen frauen sind
bevor sie ihre haltung zu der frage
erläutern wie ist es ihnen denn als
künstlerin gegangen in diesem pandemie
ja wir haben sie das erlebt wie haben
sie das gemeistert also für für ganz
ganz viele künstler die ausschließlich
in der musikbranche tätig sind und unter
anderem auch ich es ist natürlich ganz
ganz schön diese zeit momentan und wir
haben bisher noch keine auftritte haben
können seitdem quasi corona angefangen
hat und ganz ganz vielen kolleginnen von
mir oder kollegen ja den geht's halt
sehr schlecht oder ging es sehr schlecht
und man hat einfach gar keine
möglichkeit gehabt mehr mit dem womit
man mit so sein leben lang geld verdient
hat ja auf einmal das nicht mehr ausüben
zu können oder sein seinen job quasi gar
nicht mehr machen zu können und das tut
natürlich auf der einen seite auch total
wie und es ist auch irgendwie total
schrecklich irgendwie wissen zu müssen
und ich muss mir jetzt irgendwas anderes
suchen obwohl es überhaupt nicht meine
leidenschaft ist um einfach irgendwie
trotzdem ja meine wohnung weiterhin
bezahlen zu können meine familie oder
einfach essen so und das ist natürlich
eine ganz ganz schlimme zeit momentan
und wir hoffen einfach dass es ganz
schnell zu ende geht hätten sie sich
denn gewünscht dass es
bundeseinheitliche regeln gibt dass es
nicht so unterschiedlich ist das in
einem bundesland das gilt und im anderen
bundesland das also
hätten sie sich mehr zentralstaat stadt
föderalismus gewünscht war das
verwirrend für sie ich glaube auf der
einen seite ist es extrem für also ist
es nur total komplexe frage deswegen es
ist auch finde ich ganz wichtig dass
jemand im chat gesagt hat das ist total
schwierig ist das nur mit ja oder nein
zu beantworten
ich meine das ist eine sehr komplexe
geschichte für mich ist es natürlich auf
der einen seite irgendwie verwirrend
rheinland pfalz und hessen liegen direkt
aneinander unter gelten jetzt auf einmal
die regel und was macht man jetzt hier
und muss ich jetzt maske und muss ich
jetzt nicht und es ist natürlich für
jeden glaube ich irgendwo verwirrend
gewesen und ist es auch immer noch und
irgendwo wünscht man sich dann natürlich
auch so eine einheitliche klare ansage
aber vielleicht ist ja auch irgendwann
irgendwo was positives dabei dass man
schneller handeln kann dass man sagt
okay jetzt vielleicht kann man jetzt die
die geschäfte wieder aufmachen oder
jetzt kurzzeitig in rheinland pfalz weil
dort quasi die zahlen nicht so hoch sind
dann wenigstens den und den betrieb
wieder öffnen so wobei es dann
vielleicht in bayern dann ja dann wieder
wiederum ganz anders aussieht so das ist
natürlich eine ganz schwierige frage ja
dann sehe ich dass das ja genau diese
diese sehr komplexe frage müssen sie
jetzt weil der wahlomat nummer leider so
funktioniert wenn man sich durch klick
mit ja oder nein beantworten infektions
bekämpfung mehr befugnisse für den bund
stimmen sie zu bleiben sie neutral oder
stimmen sie nicht zu also ich habe in
der tat habe ich erst mal neutral
angekreuzt weil ich mich einfach noch
ein bisschen mehr damit eben vom darüber
informieren möchte mich einfach
weiterhin ja quasi schauen möchte was
kann man machen finde ich jetzt gut
finde ich nicht gut und möchte einfach
mich dann ein bisschen noch reinlesen
und deswegen habe ich erstmal die option
gibt es ja neutral
angekreuzt dann genau dafür ist der
wahl-o-mat ja auch da dass man seine
eigenen positionen hinterfragt dazu
manchen sachen sich auch überhaupt erst
mal eine meinung bildet weil gemotzt ist
schnell aber dann eine politische
haltung dazu einzunehmen das muss dann
in der tat wohl überlegt sein
dann klicken sie gerne in ruhe weiter
bis zum ende frau aussendung wir sind
dann gespannt was rauskommt am ende und
bobby wir reden hier nochmal ein
bisschen darüber welche möglichkeiten
denn ins haus stehen am sonntag und
werfen man gemeinsam blick auf die
sonntagsfrage dazu gibt es auch im
zdf-politbarometer hier ist es
projektionen rheinland pfalz wenn am
nächsten sonntag wirklich landtagswahl
wäre
übernimm du oh ja ja also erst mal ich
muss man sagen also es ist ein
unglaublich spannendes rennen hier in
rheinland pfalz ich weiß dass es für
jemanden in kiel vielleicht jetzt nicht
so unglaublich spannendes aber trotzdem
es ist sehr sehr interessant weil das
ist jetzt eine momentaufnahme das sah
vor ein paar monaten ganz anders aus da
lag die spd weit hinter der cdu die cdu
hat über monate in umfragen geführt und
jetzt erst in der vergangenen woche hat
sich das gedreht im zdf-politbarometer
dass die spd die cdu überholt hat und
jetzt fragen wir uns natürlich
wiederholt sich das jahr 2016 jetzt noch
mal war da was nämlich ganz genau so die
spd lange zurück damals trat malu dreyer
gegen julia klöckner an und auf die
letzten meter gewissermaßen hat man das
noch mal umgedreht wir als
berichterstattenden fragen uns gerade
erleben wir da so ein stück weit ein
déjà vu also das ist schon sehr
interessant kann sicher auch noch mal
über die koalitionsfrage sprechen
tatsächlich wir haben ja gerade in
rheinland-pfalz also die erste
rheinland-pfälzische ampelkoalition spd
fdp und grüne
eine frage die wir im wahlkampf jetzt in
der landtagswahl berichterstattung den
politikerinnen und politikern sehr gerne
stellen ist nur besitzern aus mit wem
möchten sie denn nachthemd
zusammenarbeiten und eine antwort die
uns die politikerinnen und politiker
sehr gerne
eben ist also erstmal wollen wir
stärkste kraft werden oder wir wollen
ein sehr gutes ergebnis haben und wenn
wir dann selber sehr gut dastehen
gehen wir selbstbewusst in
koalitionsverhandlung also das erstmalig
die standard antwort keiner legt sich da
so richtig fest kann man auch verstehen
weil man möchte ja nicht im vorfeld
schon vor der eigentlichen wahl seine
verhandlungsposition dadurch schwächen
dass man sagt naja ich schlimmer in die
richtung oder die und macht sich da so
ein stück weit abhängig aber was man
sagen kann das fand ich sehr interessant
in den vergangenen wochen wir haben ja
gerade mit den spitzenkandidatinnen der
ampel koalitionsparteien gesprochen also
malu dreyer für die spd daniela schmid
fdp und eine spiegel von den grünen und
alle drei haben immer wieder darauf
hingewiesen wie gut die ampel in den
vergangenen fünf jahren
zusammengearbeitet hat da gab es
eigentlich keinerlei attacken auch im
wahlkampf also dass die spd gegen die
grünen die grünen gross gegen die fdp
geschossen hätte die grünen vielleicht
schon hin und wieder die gesagt haben
dass sie dass sie die klimaziele von fdp
und spd als etwas unambitioniert
betrachten dass die grünen da die
einzige partei sind die wirklich voran
geht aber es gab keine richtigen
attacken und wenn ich mich jetzt zu
einer ganz persönlichen einschätzung
hinreißen lassen sollte will ich sagen
wenn es eine möglichkeit gibt
nach diesen 14 märz also nach dem
sonntag diese ampel koalition
fortzusetzen wäre meine vermutung würden
das spd fdp und grüne wahrscheinlich tun
es gibt eine user frage zu den zahlen
die wir gerade gezeigt haben michael m
fragt über youtube wie aussagekräftig
ist das politbarometer da viele schon
per briefwahl früher gewählt haben
ohne die frage also wenn du die
beantworten kannst sehr gerne waren die
politbarometer zahlen die sind letzte
woche entstanden glaube ich nicht aber
welche rolle insgesamt spielt denn die
briefwahl dieses jahr und wie viele
haben denn überhaupt schon gewählt weißt
du das ja also ich meine es wird ja
jetzt auch soweit ich das weiß der
politbarometer jetzt nicht gefragt
irgendwie was haben sie gewählt
ja also deswegen das eine schliesst das
andere jetzt nicht aus und wie diese
repräsentativen umfragen zustande kommen
das kann man ja alles bei uns auch auf
der homepage nachlesen
tatsächlich habe aber noch mal
nachgeguckt
mich heute noch mal erkundigt weil wir
gerade im rahmen der landtagswahl
berichterstattung eigentlich regelmäßig
bei der landeswahlleitung anrufen und
gerade dieses thema briefwahl abfragen
das habe ich dann vor der sendung auch
noch mal gemacht also stand heute ist es
so dass 44 prozent aller
stimmberechtigten die briefwahl
beantragt haben und jetzt gehen wir mal
also die landeswahlleitung geht von
einer wahlbeteiligung von 70 prozent aus
und das ergibt dann einen briefwähler in
den anteil von 63 prozent also 63
prozent briefwahl anteil im vergleich
bei der letzten landtagswahl 2016 lag
der anteil bei 31 prozent
ich glaube briefwahl er hat immer
zugenommen in den letzten jahren aber
das ist natürlich das ist ja quasi
doppelt so viel
ja also das auf jeden fall und natürlich
ist es eine ganz große frage inwieweit
sich das jetzt auswirkt auf die
ergebnisse ich meine wir haben jetzt die
letzte woche vor der landtagswahl da
passiert ja auch noch recht viel also
wenn wir alleine an die masken affäre
sage ich mal von der cdu denken unter
normalen umständen hätte sowas
vielleicht auch noch einen einfluss auf
die wahlentscheidung das heißt ja auch
nicht dass die landesregierung jetzt
durchmarschiert bis zum sonntag in der
korona pandemie wir besprochen haben
kann einiges schiefgehen und natürlich
auch eine wahlentscheidung kurzfristig
noch einmal beeinflussen
nur die briefwahl macht es da natürlich
schwierig wenn viele leute ihre stimme
schon abgegeben haben
zementiert das natürlich einen gewissen
unterbau und da muss man halt schauen
was am sonntag am ende unterm strich
steht dann schauen wir mal was in
unserer sendung heute unter dem strich
steht frauen sind sind sie durch und
wenn ja was ist denn herausgekommen mit
welcher partei haben sie denn heute nach
dem was sie durch geklickt haben die
höchste übereinstimmung
also ich glaube dadurch dass ich auch
etwas mich noch bei einigen themen
informieren werde es ja quasi eine etwas
kleinere partei rausgekommen die man so
jetzt erstmal nicht auf dem schirm hat
das lesen kann
walt mit 76,6 prozent wollten muss man
dazu sagen ist relativ jung und relativ
kleine partei die sich zum ziel gesetzt
hat die europäische union weiter
voranzutreiben und hat auch auf
kommunalen ebenen schon ganz gute
erfolge gezielt ist aber natürlich hier
newcomer hat sie das überrascht
ich habe in der tat schon mal den markt
gemacht und da war auch walt dabei zwar
nicht ganz weit oben aber auch dabei ich
also jetzt so überrascht hat mich
deswegen jetzt nicht so unbedingt aber
ich hätte jetzt nicht gedacht dass es
ganz ganz oben steht nun genau gerade
stand stand das falsche ist da sie sind
natürlich giuliana und nicht bobby aber
schon ist es korrigiert jetzt müssen wir
natürlich wichtiger weise dazu sagen
dass das jetzt bei ihnen rausgekommen
ist bei frauen sind ist natürlich keine
aussage darüber wen sie am sonntag
tatsächlich wählen
das soll auch ihr geheimnis bleiben und
darum soll es auch gar nicht gehen
wir wollen gar nicht wissen wenn frau
townsend welt sondern uns hat
interessiert dass sie uns daran haben
teilhaben lassen wie sie ihre politische
meinungsbildung vorangetrieben haben
frauen sind haben sie denn schon
briefwahl gemacht oder gehen sie am
sonntag wählen und sind sie stamm
wählerinnen oder haben sie sich jetzt
auch durch den wahlomat in ihrer
entscheidung noch mal ein bisschen
beeinflussen lassen das waren ungefähr
zwölf fragen auf einmal zur briefwahl
nähe haben wir haben wir noch nicht
gemacht aber wie wahrscheinlich am
sonntag dann quasi das direkt machen und
was was was war das war noch die anderen
fragen ob ich stamme ja genau
also ich genau also ich weiß nicht genau
wie man das jetzt formulieren aber ich
wähle seitdem ich wählen darf und ja die
anderen fragen sind aber nicht immer
nicht immer dieselbe partei
sie entscheiden
oder haben sie bleiben sie da einer
partei immer treu oder wechseln die
gerne also ich finde ich find's super
wichtig dass es den ballon markt gibt
weil man sich einfach da noch mal
richtig informieren kann und dass ich
meine es stehen halt jedes mal auch neue
fragen im raum und sind neue themen da
die einem irgendwie wichtiger erscheinen
oder nicht wichtig erscheinen oder was
auch immer
und deswegen finde ich es sehr gut dass
man einfach sich noch mal so eine
meinung einholen kann mit den fragen und
worum es dann auch eigentlich geht beim
wahl o mat und kann sich gleichzeitig
darüber auch noch mal informieren und
das finde ich sehr gut
super franzose den auch wenn ich wählen
gehen okay dann sag ich ganz herzlichen
dank an dieser stelle dass sie mit
gemacht haben und dass wir dabei
zuschauen durften vielen dank und viel
spaß beim wählen am sonntag dankeschön
und tschüss bobby an dich noch mal die
frage wir haben es ja am anfang schon
gesagt das ist nicht nur für die
parteien neuland sondern auch für die
journalisten und journalistinnen du bist
am sonntag auch dabei es gibt einen user
der ist großer fan von dir tamiya 16
fragt hier über youtube moderiert bobby
auch das zdf wahlstudio am sonntag sehr
sympathisch und das müssen wir leider
mit nein beantworten er ist nicht das
wahlstudio aber du wirst dabei sein
kannst du ein bisschen erzählen was du
machen willst und wie das für euch sein
wird weil das ja auch echt schwierig ist
da jetzt in den landtagen und auch wie
das berichten für euch war jetzt in den
letzten tagen
ok ich fange mit der letzten frage an
gerade also dass wir hatten ja eingangs
schon darüber gesprochen dass es für die
parteien eine ausnahme situation ist und
das ist für uns auch tatsächlich gewesen
in den vergangenen wochen und monaten
normalerweise sind wir bei diesen ganzen
veranstaltungen mit dabei und es ist
natürlich schon was anderes wenn wir
streams beobachten zum teil mit zeichen
und parallel dann aber auch in so einem
digitalen wahlstudio ein bisschen behind
the scenes drehen
aber immer die gleichen bilder generiert
ja also das heißt wir haben das
spitzenkandidaten spitzenkandidatinnen
wir haben vielleicht noch irgendein
polit promi wir haben monitor und das
war's ja das ist nicht so unglaublich
attraktiv also was uns wirklich gefehlt
hat in den letzten wochen
das waren dann diese diese großen
veranstaltung wenn ich zurückdenke an
die landtagswahl vor fünf jahren also
das ist was anderes wenn angela merkel
zur unterstützung ihrer partei in die
festhalle nach landau kommt ja oder
armin laschet zugeschaltet wird in
stream ja das fühlt sich einfach anders
an
man hat man man kann nicht so richtig
schnuppern man hat nicht so richtig das
gefühl für die bürgerinnen und bürger
welche themen kommen an mit welchen
scheitern auch die politikerinnen und
politiker vielleicht wie sieht es
wirklich bei den leuten aus das fehlt
uns gerade total und wir haben das so
gut wie möglich versucht abzubilden es
war schwierig ist bleibt schwierig und
wenn wir jetzt noch mal auf den wahltag
gucken da zieht sich das gerade mal
sofort also normalerweise ist es ja so
dass wir unsere haupt position haben von
der wir aus dann zu den
unterschiedlichen reporterinnen und
reportern schalten das war vor fünf
jahren zum beispiel so dass wir da
gestanden haben
bei der spd fraktion damals haben wir
gedreht für die aktuelle
berichterstattung das weiß ich noch
dicht gedrängt unglaubliche anspannung
es war ja auch ein ganz enges rennen
und da hat man so richtig die stimmung
gespürt und egal auf welcher wahlparty
das war
sieg niederlage dann da ist man richtig
dicht drangewesen und dieses mal ist es
so dass zb der landtag in mainz eine
ganz strenge hygiene konzept hat also
das heißt so wie ich werde jetzt eine
position haben die bis zu einem
bestimmten zeitpunkt glock 17 uhr 45 im
abgeordnetenhaus des landtags ist dann
müssen wir alle raus ja dann standen
einander kriegen überhaupt nichts mehr
mit von dem was in den fraktionssaal
passiert sondern können nur darauf
hoffen dass ab einem bestimmten
zeitpunkt wahrscheinlich nach der ersten
hochrechnung die spitzenkandidatinnen
oder vielleicht auch andere prominente
vertreter oder vertreterinnen der
parteien heraus kommen zu uns ihre sein
können ihr müsst raus weil sonst zu
viele leute auf einmal im landtag wären
weil die sobald die ersten zahlen da
sind alle von den parteien in den
landtag strömen richtig der grund dafür
nicht dass man euch das kind
berichterstattung ausschließen will
sondern es ist einfach ein räumliches
problem oder abstand problem
man kann es ja nachvollziehen es ist
schwer zu steuern gerade dieser dieser
punkt 18 uhr die erste hochrechnung
unglaublich emotionaler moment in der
regel ist das ja auch schon ein eine
ringen um die bilder jeder versucht das
beste bild jeder versucht die
entsprechenden kandidaten dann zu
bekommen und dass da natürlich das
risiko recht hoch ist das vielleicht die
abstandsregeln die hygiene konzepte
nicht eingehalten werden ist hoch der
landtag hat dann gesagt das wollen wir
von vornherein ausschließen
deswegen entzerren wir das ganze drinnen
in den fraktions sellen sind nur ganz
bestimmte anzahl von personen erlaubt
dementsprechend lassen die parteien
wahrscheinlich weniger raum für
journalisten journalisten sondern eher
für ihre eigenen leute und wir versuchen
das dann so gut es geht von draußen zu
covern bin ich sehr gespannt wie ihr das
in mainz mattig selber darf als
reporterin in stuttgart mit dabei sein
die hygiene konzepte vorschriften
regelungen sind ähnlich also wir werden
beide dort mit spannenden wahlsonntag
erleben und sie zu hause können auch
einmal spannenden wahlsonntag erleben
den zdf heute live wird mit dabei sein
daniel bröckerhoff moderiert hier und
wir freuen uns wenn sie und ihr
mitmachen genauso wie wir uns gefreut
haben dass sie und ihr heute abend dabei
wahrt und damit ganz herzlichen dank an
bobby und ganz herzlichen dank an sie zu
hause und einen schönen abend noch und
egal was sie wählen
aber wählen gehen das ist wichtig machen
sie es gut ist